I hereby pardon Liberty and Bell
President Biden is pardoning two turkeys
this year as is Thanksgiving tradition
it's a cute photo up what's less cute is
how rarely Biden uses his clemency
powers on people Biden has issued a
grand total of 12 individual pardons
during his three years in office he's
pardoned almost as many turkeys Biden
also famously issued a mass pardon for
those convicted of federal marijuana
possession that was great except it
didn't release anyone from prison
because there were no fed inmates left
on simple possession charges it's not
that there aren't worthy humans Biden
could go clemency to there are many
people for example serving very long
sentences for drug crimes thanks to the
tough on crime approach that Biden
himself championed in the Senate like
Ross R Who in 2015 was sentenced to
double life imprisonment plus 40 years
for operating a website with elicit
drugs Biden RAM for president in part on
making up for his tough on crime past so
pardon all the turkeys you want Mr
President but how about some more people
too